alright so I'm here with Adam garms who
just like connect for the xbox 360 and
it was a straight-up manny pacquiao vs
morales out there I gotta say how'd you
feel you know it's actually a lot of fun
it's a lot more tiring than you think
it'd be I mean you're actually moving
around it kind of takes a bit to
register the moves that you're doing I
noticed that it wasn't it wasn't perfect
but it was pretty spot-on it was pretty
cool an honest human being I like it so
it's it's like the wii on steroids
pretty much yeah no totally um it seems
to have a at a better fine-tuned system
like you can kind of pinpoint what
you're going for but personally I think
that it could probably use a little bit
of work I mean it's still an early game
so you know you never you never know
what they can do with this technology
ultimately you're a bunch of guys like
looking like this up there kinda I mean
it's a little better than wii sports you
know you're boxing you just laying when
you have no idea what's going on this
one there's some technique to it you
know you can aim high and you can block
high and stuff but still it's not
perfect but you can definitely see this
going into cool direction but you are so
I mean you're sweating I'm not gonna lie
you you look like me after one of my
late night tug sessions oh no it's legit
man it works you out I'm part of it
though because its hands freeze it
really makes you kind of get into it I
mean I know it's a video game but you
know when you're boxing in there you're
you're really thrown in there and you
don't need to but it's part of the fun
which I know I'm not gonna lie it's
pretty cool you don't have a puka shell
necklace so I think that's really cool
the only Xbox player without a puka
shell necklace ladies and gentlemen and
he won while he played kinect boxing
well there are three things that are
very popular and getting burned out at
an alarming rate nets 3d motion
controllers and vampires and after the
sixaxis controller sony feels that they
have found the solution to their problem
by copying the way and it just played a
game with her motion controller called
the fight and i gotta say it was about
as unresponsive did you'd probably
expect I don't get it and it's the games
based on your ability to move and
apparently my guy was getting tired when
I had a lot of energy left I was fine so
that's just stupid I mean to be fair if
everyone plays Red Seal they never would
have bought a wii but that being said
probably using the best game to showcase
for this motion controller best I can
say it right now just use a controller a
regular controller it's an analog in a
d-pad since those are fun and yes the
guy behind me playing the game
metamorphosize before your eyes but
ultimately I understand why stoneys
doing it because the motion controllers
are a big market right now I mean just
look at the we but the wii appeals to a
certain demographic and that's the
casual gamer and i just don't think
casual gamers are going to drop five
hundred seven dollars in sony product to
casually game